hey resides go and look I have a cannon
now I'll be back I feel last episode
last episode was not the greatest I had
a mental breakdown but I feel better
today thanks for asking I have the
cannon I realized I mean it takes 10
shots I'll show you how it works I want
to show you another thing first
alright look we have you can't see what
I'm pointing we have 40 inside which
means what the [ __ ] the hell are you
doing there
it's so creepy he's been there all along
but we haven't seen him because now we
have more insight look at this he's
looking at me what the [ __ ] oh it's so
disgusting
just ill ah makes me upset and my wife
my wife or is dead I think
where'd she go waifu wife or son - sama
[Music]
waifu
- get your boots what waifu
where are you cats kitty
Kaskade a wife oh okay well we kill the
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
let's keep going bros I understand why
they call it that forbidden woods now I
get it
I'm so done you mother [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh god I'm gonna have a panic
attack oh god oh god I'm gonna die I'm
dead I'm dead I'm alive I'm alive I'm
alive don't suck my face you disgusting
piece of [ __ ] oh oh good night beaut
my god can I enjoy the [ __ ] scenery
oh god what is that
it never ends does it just what the [ __ ]
are you and I'm gonna go ahead and kill
you
oh nice it's a vagina bug I think I saw
you in one of my nightmares if you
happen you know what slap up Regina bug
if you have been you know it's like a
vagina bug if you have been you know it
slap of a giant bug like you know it's
if you're happy and you know what
ah do what you want
I'm alive ah oh my god a vagina
take that
[Music]
well well what a beautiful moon I had to
love how you doing
no I will not get you biscuits you can
go up and get your own biscuits no don't
don't argue with me I have a cannon my
god I wasted why what you want you want
me to go they you want me to go there
why you're [ __ ] crazy just sitting in
a chair and pointing at me it just kind
of looked like y'all oh oh oh of course
the Vasia spider of course of course
it's raining spiders of cars you know
what I was gonna go this way anyway
Allah minions don't hurt me don't hurt
me no more all right I'm gonna go in
hello there Rob how you doing
all good mate gonna slice you up in a
bit
that was great wasn't it good tan from
stop [ __ ] kidding me
oh god oh god Romney's pissed rom is a
pissed at his guys guys chill he spawns
more mind God
okay ROM can spit that's nice good to
know
huh Ronnie Roux isn't wearing any shoes
Ronnie roux where are your shoes Rami
you crazy
where are your shoes don't spit on me
Rami ruh-roh miru what did I say oh they
do a lot of damage peace please
hey spider-friends how are you that's
great placing our next two things take
my roms oh god that was [ __ ] close
Rob fight your own battles man or I'm
gonna dodge your spit now Ron how are
they don't stop speedy disgusting
what are you doing Rob don't do the
thing where you'd roll on the belly cuz
I don't appreciate it
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go oh you have so
many friends around yourself popular
love you if so many friends sell my
friends your mom must be proud
where is Ron miru coming for you Rob
sick of your [ __ ] Rob the [ __ ] am I
supposed to dodge a Dodgers
I almost dodged your spit Rob what about
that she could stop that I appreciate it
said I appreciate it I said I appreciate
that that's what you get for being old
and ugly
don't do that again Rob stop stop
listen listen Ram listen Ram listen
listen listen listen listen it's raining
[Music]
rammie rammie say you Oh
damn
right that I'm pregnant Romney with my
cannon damn it I hate when that happens
rich old secret broken seek tonight seek
the nightmare room you born what Oh God
it's you again isn't it so you can't see
him if you have less insight which makes
him even scarier in my opinion figure
there be a light here
Oh God look at the moon it's [ __ ]
epic I wonder if it's because I get more
insight oh look they're everywhere oh my
god that is Oh God
honestly this is what like one of the
creepiest games I ever played straight
up it's [ __ ] amazing oh well I like
your hat sir except from Primark sorry
were you saying something
make oh god they're still hey grandpa
glad you found a new hobby oh god it's
so disturbing oh my god [ __ ] sake No
okay bris that thing out and it's great
Oh No oh hey how's everyone do any me
okay
and I'm big
what the [ __ ] I don't understand this
place this place is awful
all right this is cool hey how's the
money would go in my name is pretty
packed alright that's cool that's cool
let's hang out Tuesday right all right
cool
are you the one okay thanks ah yeah
that's good you doing I put it back
hey al hey how'd it go out I thought we
were friends
[Laughter]
yippee hey look at that that chain hello
hey hey that's my chair and every waking
hour cool place oh god [ __ ] just don't
hurt me
are you missed are you miss give me the
chest did I get it like what the [ __ ] is
that okay cool I hate this [ __ ] place
[Music]
man I wish this game would slow down a
love oh my get you [ __ ] not again
okay shoot right oh okay okay it's a
Cadillac I don't like living anyway oh
my god [ __ ] impossible no I give up
I think I'm supposed to go here I think
there is a boss battle I suspect a boss
Oh God don't touch me you're ugly and a
mushroom where the [ __ ] is this what is
this what is this [ __ ]
mushrooms everywhere what the [ __ ] it's
definitely a boss battle here come on
yep too many mushrooms to not be a
mushroom if you know what I mean guys
ladies one at a time please
[ __ ] sake mushrooms what'd I say they
wanted I timed in that is this doing
damage to the boss I didn't have to kill
all the mushrooms that's great I love
mushrooms mushroom boss genius of cars
just keep killing the mushrooms 1 2
mushroom big goon 1 2 mushroom big you
this isn't really not doing it is it
let's just jump into this [ __ ] hello
hello mushrooms gives me mushrooms am I
just supposed to kill a lot of mushrooms
is that what you want oh she's the main
mushroom [ __ ]
got it
oh she became a big mushy cool I don't
care if I'm your baby get the [ __ ] away
from me you're a big mushroom aren't you
well hasta la vista baby oh my god I'm a
[ __ ] boss mushroom be gone
that was [ __ ] easy the Kenan is so
[ __ ] awesome
I love it so much I would sacrifice my
firstborn baby for this Canon baby yeah
oh well we're gonna end it there thank
you for so much for watching
loving this series so far leave it like
if you agree like write a comment about
mushroom and I will see you in the next
one
stay awesome
[Applause]
[Music]